it was an Irish teacher I had in the
second grade who said you know whenever
I want something I pray to the Virgin
Mary and I ask her to ask God for it and
and uh and you know I promised something
in return and I get whatever I want like
that and I and I went
I need a bike
I went home and I prayed for a bike and
uh two weeks later I uh I walked into
the living room and there was a brand
new Mustang bike with a banana seat and
and you know Chopper handle bars sitting
in the middle of the living room and I
said what's this and they said you want
it in a raffle and it turns out I wanted
in a raffle that I never entered that a
friend of mine went into a sporting
goods store and uh put my name in the
raffle as well as his so that was two
weeks later so I've kind of been doing
that a lot did you give him the bike no
no